alors jean marc première opération les
poires oui je vais approcher les poires
avec donc un demi litre d'eau un univers
de va le savoir bien entendu et je mets
mon nom et mon vin chauffer pendant ton
bien à tort pendant une dizaine de
minutes le sens si ce sera avec sans
sucre alors qu'on annonce que les
couloirs vont maintenant on confectionne
la pâte à crêpes
voilà là elle est prête il suffit de la
laisser reposer à peu près une heure non
la main que nous avons confectionné le
sabayon alors ça me opération là comme
ce changement fait donc un quart de
litre de crème fraîche
alors une fois la crème fouettée
maintenant on confectionne le sabayon
voilà avec 4 jaunes 100 g de sucre
je mets un demi-verre de poireaux il ya
là je vais monter cet appareil donc sur
le gaz trouver du matin il est bon il
est en mousse comme ça j'ai pas du tout
dit il
je vais le mélanger avec une partie de
la crème ils ont les trois quarts de la
crème fouettée
voilà la mousse est fait je vais mettre
au frigo
en attendant de le faire la ganache
c'est une crème au chocolat tout simple
un décilitre de crem que je met à
bouillir et j'ai cassé 100 g de chocolat
du chocolat noir je viens c'est ma crème
une fois bouillie dans le chocolat gens
nus simplement
alors maintenant pour la sauce café même
procédé que pour la ganache sauf que
l'on remplace le chocolat par du café on
va maintenant s'occuper des crêtes car
l'appareil a créé par poser comme moi
voilà non je vais faire très bien
chauffer la poêle je mette mes crêpes
donc qui vont remplacer la génoise prend
4 crêpes
je m' à l'envers comme ça je verse un
petit peu de la ganache dessus sur
chacune des quatre avec une spatule joli
temps et je vais recouvrir d'une autre
est un moule mais crêpes que j'ai
préparé tout à l'heure j'ai mis une au
fond un peu de ma mousse williams une
autre couche de crêpes
maintenant je veux faire une mousse
chocolat avec ce qu'il me reste de
ganache et de crème fouettée
je verse mon appareil donc dans le
cercle
j'étale ma troisième crêpes le reste de
mousse voir la dernière crêpes et je
mets ce moule donc au congélateur
le sabayon est donc resté une heure dans
le congélateur lors maintenant vous
l'avez décors et des poires que vous
avez ciselés et qu'ajouté vous là je
vais mettre quelques marrons glacés mais
c'est le décor là c'est à chacun de voir
comme il préfère
c'est une année très très bons frais
maladie
je ne chantais